For months, streamer Steven Destiny Bonell has been at the center
of a federal lawsuit that has captivated and polarized online
communities. Throughout this ordeal, he has controlled the narrative,
presenting himself to his large audience as the primary victim
of a malicious, coordinated, and extortionate campaign. In a
recent stream, he gave his followers an update on the case, painting
a picture of a legal battle where he is the clear-headed, rational
actor and his opponents are incompetent, dishonest, and playing
games. It sounds like they're using ABMC to get to trial before
her statement gets dropped. Then I I think that's their goal.
Their goals are just like they lied on the complaint in order
to survive motion to dismiss, and now they have Abby to try to
survive summary judgement. And the goal is to just like kick
it to trial as much as possible while wasting as much of my time,
money, and reputation as possible. A simple, clean narrative,
but is it an honest one? Today, we going to deconstruct the claims
Destiny is making now using the most powerful counter evidence
available. Destiny's own words from his own past streams. We
will map his current statements against the very court documents
and private messages he himself has read to his audience. This
is not about opinion. This is about holding a public figure accountable
to his own record. Let's begin.
In his recent update, Destiny repeatedly frames the entire lawsuit
as nothing more than a frivolous game, a disingenuous ploy designed
solely to harm him. Demand letter from her for $500,000 saying
she was going to sue me. So, they either lied about that or um
who the No, it's all just a game to them. So, so if you're dodging
deposition everything, I don't know how I don't know how you
can maintain that.
it sounds like they're using ABMC to get to trial before her
statement gets dropped. Then even if you had abused Abby and
the evidence was real, why does that strengthen Jane Do's case?
At this point for their filings, they only file stuff in court
to try to attack my reputation. That's the main goal. So, it
doesn't matter if it's directly related to the case or not. I
think it's evidenced by most of their filings. Number one, it's
all just a game. The main goal is to attack my reputation.
This is the story he wants you to believe now. But it is a grotesque
oversimplification
that directly contradicts the far more serious and complex narrative
that he himself meticulously laid out in his 54-minute video
manifesto. In that video, he wasn't describing a game. He was
describing a tragedy. reading aloud messages from the plaintiff
Pixie that depicted a person in a state of profound crisis in
some manner in which she would expose me after taking her own
life.
Her message to me was, "Hi, Steven. As my life on this earth
comes to a close, I want to ask you to please be more careful
with the people who place their trust in you in the future. Life
is unfair, but you should do your best in preventing that, not
contributing to it." I said, "Hold up there. What's up?" I wasn't
actually sure if this was a super serious message or not, cuz
I'd never seen anything like this before from her, but
I'm just tired of living anymore. It's a matter of time until
my family discovers what happened, and I feel like there is no
way to obtain justice. I don't want to bring a case against you,
but I think you'll continue to send nudes to people, even without
their consent. Bringing a case against you would mean going public,
which is the equivalent of a death sentence for me either way.
So, I feel like the best thing to do uh is for me to kill myself
and schedule a post just detailing my feelings on what on what
happened to try to ensure a situation like this doesn't happen
again.
So, this was me sending the message to her. She replies, "It's
more complicated than that. I feel like there's no justice for
what's been done. I feel like people for the rest of my life
are going to try to send it to my family or workplace or wherever
I go.
Uh I feel extremely violated with how so many people saw me non-consensually
in a vulnerable position. I feel like people are always going
to use this as proof that I slept my way into whatever achievement
I garner. I Destiny himself provided the evidence that this situation
began not as a game to attack his reputation, but from a place
of claimed violation, emotional distress, and ideiation.
While he later framed this as an attempt at extortion, he is
now erasing that entire context. He is dishonestly reducing the
gravity of the situation he established to present a simpler,
more palatable story where he is the sole victim of a meaningless
attack. The narrative has shifted from this person is threatening
and demanding money to it's all just a game. This isn't an update,
it's a
One of the most crucial figures in the lawsuit is a witness named
Abby, who the plaintiff wants to add to the complaint. In his
new video, Destiny makes a stunningly bold and definitive claim
about the evidence she has provided.
That I sent her a bunch of stuff of um Pixie, but I mean, that's
not true. And again, in um in court, they admitted that Abby
never gave them any evidence whatsoever
that I'd sent her anything.
they admitted she never gave them any evidence whatsoever.
This is a clear, unambiguous, and factual claim about the court
proceedings. It is also a complete and demonstrable lie proven
false by a previous stream where Destiny read the public court
filings aloud to his own
Uh motion for leave to file redacted evidence in support of the
DE. Oh, we have evidence from this anonymous person. Oh boy.
Okay, this is the only witness keeping the whole case alive.
This is the big one, boys.
He acknowledges the filing is to submit evidence. He calls this
witness the only one keeping the whole case alive. He then proceeds
to read the exhibit that the plaintiff's lawyer submitted to
the court, which they claim is evidence from
By the way, Dustin sends me tapes all the time and he thinks
I don't know the girls in them, but I have videos of him.
Oh, thank we Okay. And we censored her name. This this doesn't
even exist. And Pixie like
Lympho, he just sent me another one. Haven't opened it.
Let's be perfectly clear. Destiny is free to argue that this
evidence is fake, doctorred, or inadmissible.
In fact, on his stream, he did just that, complaining that the
screenshot was edited. But that is a world away from his new
claim that the plaintiff's lawyers admitted they have no evidence
whatsoever. The court documents he broadcast to his thousands
of viewers show the plaintiff's lawyers submitting a sworn declaration
from Abby and an exhibit they are presenting as evidence. For
Destiny to now claim they admitted to having nothing is a blatant
falsehood. He is conflating his disagreement with the evidence
with the nonexistence of that evidence. This isn't spin. It is
a direct and dishonest misrepresentation of the court record.
Destiny doesn't just lie about the evidence from Abby. He also
attempts to rewrite her entire motivation for participating in
the lawsuit. He plants a seed of doubt, framing her as a pawn
who was coerced by his opponent. And then finally later on, I
don't know if they bullied or threatened Abby to do false testimony
or she decided to do it all on her own, but they got her now
to basically lie on their behalf. He doesn't know if she was
bullied or threatened by the plaintiff's team. He presents this
as a reasonable possibility, but once again, his own prior review
of the court documents tells a very different story. The filings
he read aloud allege a pervasive atmosphere of fear, not originating
from the plane of slowness, but from Destiny himself and his
followers. Indeed, several witnesses, including those that provided
declarations in support of plain dismotion for learning injunction,
have expressed fear of being publicly targeted or doxed. This
is not a real thing for the What are we talking We're do what
are you publicly targeted by defendant and or his followers and
have indicated that they are unwilling to participate in discovery
or testify unless their dies remain confidential. Oh my god.
What
I'm sorry but like this is we're in the big boy world now and
we're if you want to be a big boy and you want to come and do
court stuff that's fine but we're going to move past the this
is my Twitter account and this is my Reddit and now we're using
our real life identities. In this video, the defendant further
violates my privacy publishing. There's almost 1 million followers.
Out of context, private messages. Oh, I'm sorry. Do we need more
context with the private messages? Out of context. I'm sorry.
Is Hassan suing me now?
The three women that provided declarations under sealance order
plain dismotion for learning injunction expressed fear of being
publicly targeted or doxed by defendant and or his followers
and indicated they're unwilling to participate in discovery or
testify unless their identities remain confidential. Well, but
two of these
the Hannah person,
three of these witnesses have expressed to me fear that their
physical well-being could even be put at risk if they attempt
to pursue justice. Oh my
Attached here too is exhibit C is a true correct copy of my conversation
with one of those witnesses whose screen name is blank where
she communicates her fear of
The plaintiff's entire legal argument for filing witness declarations
under seal, an argument Destiny spent hours dissecting on stream,
is that the witnesses are afraid of him. His new narrative, where
he casually speculates that the plaintiff's side is the one bullying
witnesses, is a complete reversal. He is projecting the very
accusations leveled against him onto his opponents, conveniently
omitting that this is a core point of contention in the case.
He's not just misstating a fact, he's flipping the entire dynamic
of the case on its head. When discussing the plaintiff's attempt
to formally add Abby to the lawsuit by amending their complaint,
Destiny portrays it as a trivial, almost automatic procedural
move that is impossible to fight. But like but that's just like
a process procedural like we should oppose everything but the
I mean just amending a complaint there's I don't know if there's
any way that you could stop somebody from amending amending a
I don't know if there's any way that you could stop it. He presents
this to his audience as a minor procedural inevitability
essentially shrugging his shoulders.
This could not be further from the truth.
Not only is it possible to fight such emotion, his own legal
team is fighting it vigorously, making an argument that he himself
has read on stream. While Banell has no objection to nonparty
law voluntarily removing the video from his website called Kiwi
Farms. After all, Bonel did not publish the video to that website.
Plaintiff's motion seeking a court order compelling law to do
anything is improper and must be denied for several reasons.
First, as raised in vinyl's answer and explained in his opposition
to plaintiff spending motion or pending motion for preliminary
injunction, this court lacks subject matter jurisdiction because
the federal statute under which plaintiff seeks relief was not
in effect at the time of the alleged dissemination of the video.
This is still true. This is fatal to the entire case, but we'll
see if maybe they've got another person to come out. Second,
Lawcal, a Texas based corporation, is not a party to this case.
Law is free to voluntarily remove any content from its site without
a court order. True. His own lawyers are not shrugging their
shoulders. They are arguing that the motion to amend should be
denied because the entire case is fatally flawed from the start.
This is the opposite of saying there's no way to stop it. It
is a serious fundamental legal challenge to the very foundation
of the lawsuit.
Destiny is engaged in a rhetorical slight of hand. He presents
his opponent's legal strategy as a simple, desperate formality
while his own top tier lawyers are treating it as a critical
battleground.
He is actively and dishonestly downplaying the seriousness and
complexity of the legal fight to his audience.
Perhaps the most jarring contradiction comes when we compare
how Destiny currently describes the declarations and witnesses
to how he described them when he first read the filings. In his
new video, he dismisses their sworn statements as meaningless.
Every single one of these people had either deleted their accounts
or apparently said they were too scared to testify. Uh none of
the uh declarants that they've brought on are declaring anything
relevant to the case. It's just random blog posting in court
docs. So, they're trying to amend the original complaint to Abby
because she's the only one that keeps the case alive. Random
blog posting. Nothing relevant to the case. This is a stunning
reversal from his initial panicked reaction when he first read
these same documents.
Far from being irrelevant, he identified the declaration from
Abby as the single most important element of the entire proceeding.
Uh motion for leave to file redacted evidence in support of the
de Oh, we have evidence from this anonymous person. Oh boy.
Okay, this is the only witness keeping the whole case alive.
This is the big one, boys.
How can a witness be both the only one keeping the whole case
alive and also be submitting nothing relevant to the case? How
can their declaration be both the big one and also random blog
posting? The answer is simple. It can't. Destiny is telling two
different stories. When he wants to portray himself as being
under serious unfair attack, the witness is a critical threat.
But when he wants to portray the lawsuit as frivolous and baseless,
the very same witness and their evidence become irrelevant noise.
He changes the narrative to whatever suits his emotional and
rhetorical needs at that moment, regardless of the truth. When
we hold Destiny's current simplified narrative up against his
own past broadcasts, a clear pattern emerges.
It is a pattern of deliberate
He reduces a conflict that he himself framed as a tragedy involving
threats into a simple game.
He fabricates a claim that his opponents admitted to having no
evidence when he himself showed the evidence they submitted.
He projects the very serious allegations of witness intimidation
made against him onto his accusers.
And he dishonestly downplays the gravity of legal maneuvers that
his own highric lawyers are treating as a life ordeath struggle
for the case. This isn't an honest man giving a transparent update
to his audience. It is a media savvy personality engaged in narrative
warfare. He is actively memorying the inconvenient details, fabricating
claims about the court record and twisting the facts to fit a
story of his own victimization.
The goal is to simplify a messy, complex, and deeply damaging
case into a black and white story where he is the flawless hero
besieged by incompetent, malicious fools. But the record, his
own record, tells a very different story. Thank you for joining
me today and tune in next time. Drop a like if you enjoyed the